est-ce que vous pensez que François
Cluzet laissera une trace dans le cinéma
français je pense qu'il en laissera
aucune pourquoi
alors on va faire du bien à votre ego on
va vous faire une interview à l'un de
l'autre
François accusé est une star au Japon
François n'est pas une star au Japon que
pensez-vous de François Cluzet l'homme
François Cluzel l'homme et quelqu'un de
danse de complexe et de tout à fait
attachant qui mérite vraiment d'être
découvert plus plus largement est-ce que
vous pensez que François Cluzet est un
bon acteur François Cluzet certainement
un des meilleurs acteurs qu'il y a en
France en ce moment le public adore
François Cluzet François Cluzet n'est
pas encore autant aimé qu'il le serait
bientôt
est-ce que François Cluzet a atteint
aujourd'hui une certaine sérénité
François cluzen atteindra vraiment
jamais une sérénité ou alors c'est quand
il sera refroidi complètement
non François Cluzet est quelqu'un quand
même de relativement inquiet de
relativement énervé par les dirigeants
politiques relativement énervé par les
acteurs qui jouent comme des pieds
relativement énervé par l'humiliation
que subissent les Noirs les gros les
Juifs donc
très serein ne le sera jamais je crois
on dit que François Cluzet est devenu
beau gosse il en pense quoi François
Cluzet dire que François Cluzet a quitté
le bar et évidemment quittant la bière a
perdu quelques joues voilà
pensez que François Cluzet doit beaucoup
à son physique François Cluzet avait un
physique qui lui permettait de jouer
tout c'est à dire un physique médium
vous voyez il peut jouer en même temps
les fils de bonne famille en même temps
les fils d'ouvriers donc dans ce métier
est une bonne chose puisque vous êtes
souvent dans le casting de fait et voilà
est-ce que vous pensez que François
clizet se définit plus comme un acteur
comme un comédien a sûrement François
Cluzet comme un acteur je sais
évidemment chiant parce que j'ai
beaucoup d'amis qui sont comédiens mais
moi j'ai pris le parti d'essayer d'être
spontané de ramener le rôle à moi ce qui
fait toute la différence avec le théâtre
avec le personnage je me suis pris les
pieds sans cesse dans ces histoires de
personnages un jour j'ai décidé
d'arrêter de me prendre les pieds dans
le tapis et de ramener le personnage à
moi est-ce que vous pensez que François
Cluzet laissera une trace dans le cinéma
français je pense qu'il en laissera
aucune
pourquoi parce que je pense que pour
laisser une trace il faut faire sa
promotion personnelle en permanence et
que finalement la trace ça à avoir avec
la postérité c'est à dire avec des
grands films et que je n'en ai pas fait
encore assez donc vous pensez que
François Cluzet n'aura jamais une rue à
son nom par exemple mais de tout cœur
j'espère n'avoir jamais une rue à mon
nom
est-ce que François Cluzet est fier
d'avoir honorer toutes les femmes qui se
sont présentées à François Cluzet on y
est
François Cluzet a eu beaucoup de
manquements en ce qui concerne l'honneur
aux femmes qui sont présentées à lui
vous savez comme un peu dans le film moi
je suis un timide et très longtemps les
femmes n'aiment pas les timides parce
qu'elles sont élevées aussi dans l'idée
du prince charmant qui doit faire le
premier pas alors le timide lui
évidemment à temps clairement
un effet c'est pas très fort le timide
c'est pas très viril en fait pour les
femmes exactement c'est tout le problème
est-ce que François Cluzet aime bien
parler comme Alain Delon François Cluzet
déteste parler comme un est-ce que
François aimerait bien que c'est un
service termine non François Cluzet
préférerait qu'elle continue et ben non
elle se termine et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de innarditude abonnez-vous
et mettez un pouce bleu